the choices in November have all but
been decided either you're with her or
you're with fear throughout this primary
many have become disillusioned by
American democracy
sorry mmm democracy some say the system
is rigged
I say that's just how it doesn't work
but wait I know how to stay true to my
values and participate in the election
I'll vote third party third parties in
the United States exist the Libertarian
Party the Green Party the Working
Families Party and yes the rent is too
damn high party led by Jimmy McMillan
who is running for president in 2016 but
not on a platform of affordable housing
but on legal prostitution for senior
citizens because as he states on his
website all I want is for someone to
take care of my needs and want this Bona
is too damn high but here's the thing
about third parties as important as they
may be they're always seen as spoilers
like Bruce Willis was dead the whole
time Dumbledore dies or Donald Trump
will start World War 3 through 5 because
within the USS current two-party system
there's no way to gain real traction
without inevitably helping the
front-runner of the opposing party even
Trump knows it and he's goading Sanders
into running independently something
that the campaign has said Bernie won't
do the only running he'll be doing is
away from his own diehard fan bros what
have I done
Sanders knows the score when it comes to
third parties take Ralph Nader the Green
Party candidate who also ran on a
platform of campaign finance reform and
universal health care in the 2000
election he got 97 thousand votes in
Florida votes that may have gone to
Democrat Al Gore some even blame Nader
for the Bush years even Bernie alluded
to it did I agree with a lot of what
Ralph Nader I have to say yeah I did
that I want George Bush to become
President of the United States no one
did not wait does even Bernie forget
that Florida
stopped their recount effectively
handing the presidency to Bush have we
no collective memory anymore our hanging
chads just now terms for frat boy keg
stands and then there's Ross Perot the
billionaire who ran as an independent in
92 Republicans believe the 19 percentage
points he got cost George Bush Senior
the election media outlets still call an
independent run pulling a Ross Perot
which is weird because to me pulling a
Ross Perot means running the world's
first and most boring TED talk about the
US economy during prime time here's the
picture on our country's debt look at
how it's grown over the years here's
what's happened to your dollar and
here's what's happening to the audience
I am currently losing the star search
another thing to know is that we have a
winner-take-all system so unlike
democracies with proportional
representation if you don't win it all
you get nothing
kind of like my third grade spelling bee
you spell 10 words right but doubt has a
B in it if we had proportional
representation we might have a plurality
of voices and political leanings rather
than a country that looks like this it
looks like a game of we don't believe in
evolution twister right hand ignorant
even if you do want to vote third party
you probably can't the Maine third
parties aren't by default on every state
ballot they have to petition to be there
and all independent candidates have to
follow equally mind-numbing ly
complicated rules that differ from state
to state just to get voters to see their
names Texas law says for example that an
independent running for president needs
to collect nearly 80 thousand signatures
in only two months but for some reason
only from people who did not vote in the
primary which must lead to some pretty
desperate canvassing excuse me sirs you
have 45 minutes to grasp the concept of
democracy because Socrates once said
then over in Georgia where the ballot
access laws are so strict they're
currently being fought in court
independents have to submit their
petition to run no earlier than 9:00
a.m. on the fourth Monday in June and no
later than 12:00 p.m. on the second
Tuesday in July preceding the primary
election before the blood moon after El
Nino and eight hours before the Braves
play third party and independent runs
have therefore become the saddest f you
to an indomitable East Act process so
what are we left with
the usual two-party choices with
wringing endorsements like billionaire
mark
for Hillary because the devil you know
is better than the devil you don't know
even when House Speaker without a
backbone Paul Ryan held a press
conference specifically to condemn the
racist cheese it that's hijacked his
party he still says Trump is the lesser
of two evils
it's absolutely unacceptable but do I
believe that Hillary Clinton is the
answer no I do not yes you do
you're smart and scared for all they're
spoiling third parties do still
influence Republicans and Democrats as
boring as Perrault's commercials were he
made national debt a major issue and
forced Bill Clinton to address it as
president and Bernie knew that running
as a Democrat was probably a smarter
move than running independent he's
rattled the cage of the Democratic Party
from the inside because Bernie knows
Mark Cuban knows everyone knows the
rigged nests of this system means there
can never be a viable third party
candidate no one can do it under these
conditions I mean no one breaking news
we've just received word that Jesus
Christ has returned to earth and not
only that it appears he has announced
his campaign for President of the United
States as a third party candidate I'm
joined now by Democratic strategist guy
Wilson and Republican strategist barb
borne soon for their thoughts barb let's
start with you what does this news mean
for the general well first of all Wow
Christ is risen praise him and for
Republicans it could not have come at a
worse time why is that
Kagan what the Republican Party needs is
unity not division and I think at this
point Jesus is just gonna sweep up all
those sweet votes from the grand old
party so you're not happy with his
decision to run as an independent as
much as I love Jesus Christ and hope one
day to walk hand-in-hand with him in the
kingdom of heaven Hillary Clinton is
literally the devil so as much as it
pains me to say this
a vote for Jesus is a vote for the devil
interesting point Kagan I think barb is
being completely disingenuous here Jesus
Christ returning the earth and running
for president is actually a dirty trick
by the Trump campaign to split the
Hillary vote how so
tell me if this sounds familiar a
campaign centered on universal health
care stopping the moneylenders and
encouraging revolution all being
promoted by a very old Jewish man
he's clearly courting Sanders voters and
will spoil for the Dems but isn't it
good for a democracy to have third party
candidates
listen all he'll do is split the vote
just look at his poll numbers fifty-one
percent of Americans questioned if he
was even reborn in this country well
this is a cable news first two pundits
from different sides of the aisle who
agree oh I'm getting word now that yes
joining us live via satellite we have
third-party candidate for president
Jesus Christ mr. Christ thank you for
joining us hello now why are you running
as a third party candidate I'm the way
the truth and the light I'm the king of
kings
no he's pulling a Ross Perot it's clear
Jesus I suppose my question for you is
why are you running now well in
Revelation I said I will come on me as a
thief and thou shalt not know what hour
I will come upon me so I came now see
Keegan even he knows he's a thief
Keegan it's been two thousand years
since Jesus or should I say zombie Jesus
has passed a lot Sambi Jesus
yes I believe she's referring to Donald
Trump's nickname for you he recently
tweeted zombie Jesus is a shill for
crooked Hillary to split the vote sad
mr. Christ your response but I'm Jesus
let me read you some more tweets here
are some from Hillary fans sorry Jesus
it's her turn Jesus bros are rubbing
their bro thoughtless ISM in the face of
Hillary fans and some from Trump
supporters Jesus may be a carpenter but
there's no way he can build a wall like
Trump and Jesus is a secret Muslim how
do you respond to all that I uh I
forgive them on the plus side mr. Christ
polls show that you do have a huge
advantage with Mormons
what's a Mormon honestly Keegan in this
political reality how does mr. Christ
expect to beat both Hillary and Trump
well as it says in my book which I
assume you've all read
the dead believers in Christ shall rise
so that's a few hundred million
registered voters from me yes Jesus
you're actually not on the ballot in 20
states that doesn't even seem fair and
good luck getting enough signatures in
Texas zombie Jesus I just I don't
understand why he had to come back now
why couldn't he wait for years to come
back to earth this is the most important
election my children don't you remember
the book of Matthew when I foretold that
I would return during the apocalypse
will the apocalypse that I was referring
to was this election please clap huh I
see now what about being Hilary's
running mate I can't she takes money
from Wall Street we'll have to leave it
there mr. Christ thank you for coming on
the show and dying for my sins anytime